hi there steve kaufman here the linguist
on language blogs
uh i want to follow up on the discussion
we had about uh srs space repetition
systems
uh which i tend to be a little bit
of a skeptic on
uh and i want to talk about that and
about learning chinese characters
um i believe that the most important
thing in language learning is how
motivated you are how interested you are
how emotionally attached you are to what
you're doing
so for that reason all the scientific
supposedly scientific
explanations about how you need to
review something
20 minutes after first seeing it and
then x hours and then next days and
stuff
i just don't buy it because
words attach to us in different ways for
different reasons some of which
might be explained some of which are not
explainable
um
to have some algorithm which dictates
that you must review it every day so
that the
algorithm can be accurate so that you
meet the word again in seven days and 10
days and 15 days whatever it is
even if it works i don't want it i'm not
interested in it
i like reviewing flash cards i enjoy it
as one of the commenters
at my blog said it's a bit like doing
you know your scales before your piano i
mean it's a good exercise it helps you
focus on the language it helps you
notice certain things but you're not
gonna i mean i've saved over thirty
thousand words in russian i'm not gonna
review them all in some
anki or super memo system that's not me
however
other people like to do it fine
i think it's very important that you
find the
type of language learning that that you
like
now and it's not but it's not obvious to
me the time spent the hour you may spend
or half an hour you may spend
religiously reviewing your flashcards
daily
is time better spent than listening to
something or reading something of
interest to you
for that same period of time because we
only have so much time available
today i study russian i have an hour an
hour and a half a day between sitting in
the car and exercising and so forth
a little bit of portuguese here and
there i mean i have a limited amount of
time
in 1968 i was sent to hong kong by the
canadian government to learn chinese
that was my job period i had to do it i
was spending five six seven hours a day
doing nothing but i took time out to
play tennis go for a run go watch a
movie go and eat
and court my future wife
but
five six hours a day or so was spent
learning chinese
in
eight months i learned four thousand
characters
uh i learned enough to write an exam the
british british foreign service exam
that required me
to translate newspaper editorials from
english into chinese from chinese into
english to
write again by hand all this by hand
diplomatic note so i had to learn all
these characters what did i do we didn't
have high six
system for learning kanji we didn't have
uh my system you know super memo
uh i took a typical um squared
exercise book that a chinese
school boy or school child i used to
have
and i had a
flash card uh cards
a thousand of the most common most
frequently used chinese characters and i
would take 10 to start with and i would
write the first one down this
squared
exercise book and uh write it 10 times
then i would place it three columns over
but i would write the meaning or the
sound and then i'd pick up another one
and i'd do the same and within about
three or four of these i'd run into just
by working my way up and down this uh
you know the columns in the squared uh
exercise book i'd run into the first
character again
following uh spaced repetition
principles i'd run into it before i'd
forgotten it completely and then i would
repeat it and i would write it another
10 times and then i would move that
further to the right on my exercise book
and i would keep on doing this with my
10 characters until i kind of halfway
knew them
fully realizing that i would forget most
of them so i figured if i got a 50
survival rate that was good i eventually
got up to 30 a day
but then i started doing it less and
less religiously
uh and past the 1000 or so that were in
my
box
mostly when i encountered new characters
i would write them out five six seven
times and that was good enough because
there are connections and the same is
true in learning vocabulary there are
connections so you have to start
focusing on connections in the case of
characters there are components that
repeat
uh these characters appears and appear
in compound with other characters to
form certain meaning so you have to
become very attentive
to how things work together just like
when you're learning vocabulary you're
learning
uh how these words change which words
they're often used together with you're
starting to notice things and so you
notice them when you're reading you'll
notice them you notice them when you're
listening
so basically that's all i did so a bit
of a
a short term srs home
spun variety
for the first thousand and thereafter
heavily oriented towards a lot of
interesting reading
so that you know during this eight-month
period
most of my time was spent reading and
listening and learning about modern
chinese history ancient chinese history
the thoughts of mao zedong because 68
the cultural revolution
uh you know uh chinese literature of the
twenties and thirties laosha mao don
people like that
so i got all of this i didn't spend i
must say i didn't religiously review my
characters they kind of just came
uh in a sort of organic way i'm a bit of
a taoist in my book i mentioned drunza
do what you like to do do it often
enjoy what you're doing follow your
interests and you'll get there so and
i'm gonna keep my videos short because
i'm having all kinds of trouble moving
from imovie in fact it doesn't work
anymore from imovie to google i don't
know what they've done
they won't let me change my email
address at google
i don't know what they expect i'm happy
to pay if that's what they want they
just set you up in a catch 22 situation
where you can no longer
upload movies from imovie that's
completely [ __ ]
but anyway
um
so now i have to load them to quicktime
and that takes forever and sometimes it
fails so hopefully this one will get
through thank you for listening bye for
now